>> Tucker: MUCH OF THE MEDIA
HAVE MOCKED THE EXISTENCE OF
UNIDENTIFIED FLYING OBJECTS AND
THE U.S. PENTAGON HAS BEEN
STUDYING THIS SUBJECT FOR QUITE
A LONG TIME.
APPARENTLY THEY WILL SOON
RELEASE SOME OF THEIR FINDINGS
WHICH WILL REMAIN CLASSIFIED.
ACCORDING TO A NEW REPORT IN THE
U.S."THE NEW YORK TIMES," THE U.
MAY HAVE VEHICLES THAT WERE "NOT
MADE ON THIS EARTH."
THEY HAVE ALSO RELEASED FOOTAGE
OF UFO SIGHTINGS INCLUDING A
2004 ENCOUNTER RECORDED FROM AN
ADVANCED NAVY FIGHTER JET.
COMMANDER DAVID FREIGHTER IS A
RETIRED NAVAL AVIATOR WHO WANTS
SOMETHING HE COULD NOT EXPLAIN
IN SCIENCE CAN’T EXPLAIN AND WE
ARE HONORED TO HAVE THEM ON
TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO TELL US IF YOU THINK THIS IS
BEING MISINTERPRETED.
ACCORDING TO THE U.S. NEW
"NEW YORK TIMES," THE U.S. HAS
SOME EVIDENCE OF SOME SORT OF
EVIL NOT MEET ON THIS EARTH, IS
THAT WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE?
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT TO ME.
I NEVER WANT TO SPECULATE WHAT
THE GOVERNMENT TRULY HAS BUT I
WOULD SAY THERE IS STUFF OUT
THERE.
THE FOUR OF US THAT CHASED THE
TIC TAC IN 2004 HAVE ATTESTED
MULTIPLE TIMES THAT WHAT WE SAW
EXCEEDED ANYTHING THAT WE HAD IN
OUR INVENTORY AND WAS FAR
SUPERIOR TO THE AIRPLANES THAT
WE HAD AT THE TIME.
SO I WOULD SAY YES, THERE’S
SOMETHING OUT THERE AND
HOPEFULLY THE GOVERNMENT DOES
HAVE STUFF.
>> Tucker: IT’S WE SPOKE
BEFORE ABOUT THIS AND YOU
SUGGESTED THE OBJECT THAT YOU
SAW THAT YOU TASTE, THE TIC TAC,
BEHAVED IN WAYS THAT CHALLENGE
YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
AERONAUTICS AND PHYSICS AND YOU
DIDN’T THINK IT WAS LIKELY THAT
THAT OBJECT BELONGS TO A FOREIGN
MILITARY.
DO YOU THINK THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
HAS CONCLUDED THAT THIS IS NOT
RUSSIA, CHINA OR SOME OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> I’M PRETTY SURE OF THAT.
JUST BY SOME OF THE PHONE CALLS
THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN, SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WE HAVE TALKED TO IN THE
GOVERNMENT, THEY ARE UNAWARE OF
WHAT THIS IS AND I THINK THAT
TIES DIRECTLY WITH THE
EAST COAST CITING, WITH THE
GIMBAL VIDEO, AND I WOULD BE
WILLING TO SAY, BECAUSE I’M IN
CONTACT WITH A LOT OF THESE
PEOPLE, THERE ARE MORE INCIDENTS
THAT ARE STARTING TO COME OUT
AND PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
REPORT INSIDE OF THE GOVERNMENT
CHANNELS, THE THINGS THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
I THINK YOU’RE SEEING IT FROM
THE PAST BECAUSE IT ALWAYS HAD
THAT TABOO, YOU ARE NOT FINDING
PEOPLE FROM THE PAST IS THAT I
SAW THIS.
AND WHEN I DID I WAS TOLD NOT TO
SAY ANYTHING.
SO I THINK SINCE 2017 THE WORLD
IS STARTING TO CHANGE, BECAUSE
OF LACK OF PUBLICITY AND BECAUSE
OF THE ATTENTION IN THE SENATE
AND THE CONGRESS.
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE LIKE
MARCO RUBIO AND THE INTEL
COMMITTEE, AND THE GOVERNMENT
DOES HAVE STUFF, AND THAT, AND
WHERE IS THAT ALL THAT.
JUST BY ODDS, SOMETHING WOULD BE
HERE.
>> SO THAT RAISES THE QUESTION
WHY THE SECRECY?
CLEARLY THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS
LIED FOR THE PUBLIC FOR MAYBE 73
YEARS, WHY DO YOU THINK?
>> THE OTHER ONE PRIMARILY WAS
SENT OUT TO PROVE THAT IT WASN’T
BOARD TO MAKE EXCUSES OF WHY IT
WASN’T.
IF SOMETHING LANDS IN YOUR FRONT
YARD IT THERE’S NO REASON TO
DENY IT EXISTED ORDER FOR THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEN WHY WOULD
YOU HIDE IT.
WHY WASN’T IT THOROUGHLY
INVESTIGATED AT THE TIME FOR
SOMETHING THAT LITERALLY COULD
PENETRATE, AND NOTHING WAS DONE
UNTIL ABOUT 2009.
>> Tucker: IT THERE’S A STORY
HERE THAT A LOT OF US CAN’T WAIT
TO SEE.
FINALLY, DO YOU FEEL VINDICATED?
>> I NEVER -- IF YOU COULD SAY
THAT BUT MOST OF THE FELLOW
AVIATORS THAT KNOW THE GROUP OF
US, WE WERE NEVER LIKE CHASTISE
OR, YOU GET RIPPED BUT IT WAS
NEVER LIKE YOU WERE CRAZY OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
PEOPLE TAKE YOU SERIOUSLY BY
DEFINITION.